This
next excerpt is from original tape W sixty two.
Friends
last night at five thirty we do
here working on this is that.
We have a small one and they won it
together. And then I got a basically me that's seven four hundred fifty seven
for right.
Fifty six thirty in the morning.
To seven thirty global.
Now.
Yes
for five of us together
when we go up to places
like Homer. At the Center for
the rest of us
were kept from
the summer season
and the guy you know is not our
cars but we got we got a blueberry leg and then
later on I blew back and I know
like you know a very big if your best because now they catch you if you go
today and buy a back you know that's a very close they've got something in my leg. I do
but it's like a different kind
of where you
live and then nine another guy every
day I was going to need another
car. See my last message.
You know I'm worried that
my son. Sure.
I'm I'm really not much of this.
Where somebody has to be.
But. You gave that
there is see everybody getting those the fans the dentist visit the
school yard I have
friends in the guys who look around a circle with Sean the guy says right
there is another guy he's got a stable. He's a
bear the guy goes to the fence and I can't tell anybody
else that he said the guy said
there. When he went over there goes you can just send
everybody coming and we don't want the guy sitting down exactly hypno by his
glass somebody that's
all that and then the other guy had to run over to come back and get somebody
else and then the other guy was down in the guys sitting down T.V. that we're trying to
get somebody
else to be you know.
I'm like oh yeah.
First I did not get
you used to that I'm often.
You know. That's in a way. Now we're always saying
that it's the last
one says it is that that's
come and then they got it to that I who says
that. You
from watching you
know what it's done or not and
what you know my
son you promised to
take you next.
That you know just yes. Much.
You can be
stopped by
so first. School. Time.
Over here we start to the do it
ten times that you know
across twenty nine seconds go across a come back.
You have a time. You have no time you know my time
is dating are.
For class. Now that I've got it at
that
fine. Play.
I'm playing some time.
And you
see if you have any you
think now I can and sometimes I look at it as
wiring a little late Sunday hike to me that my Saturday going to Cancun.
But you have some of this is what you.
Could you could you describe. Let's assign some programming some of these
joy
show. That no one is by doing is
a Sullivan
Show. Worse than you remember some things and.
I have had
on that. The famed head. You
know so
I had a lot of them felt was you good that
they know that especially you know how different was
it was if I
happened
to him. And I did and
I'd like to see months of pictures Saturday.
You like movies and
just you know what you have you have one uses.
I'm some.
See that there's you know this movie they give
out a
sleigh and then the sound guys got
together like those people in the seven
cars.
For twenty nine and two. But you know there were seven people in the
coming back. There's a lot of
people then. And I
don't know why they do. The whiners I mean yes because there's only
on people motorcycle you know have fights and
I know I go so that I just get on
T.V. They got vaccine in the hand and I like Fox and I think I let into a
few. Yeah.
I think we are going
to work. Well.
I bought people. Six fifteen sixteen
seventeen. Just before. Yes I know if
you know when this shack I was on
the one hundred twenty seven in the boxing thing. Probably got to
go with that about other people but before you get
me. Here you know what you gotta win to fight.
Your career
right now. I wanted to
cut you.
Right back to work the movie
with us. There never
was part of me that made him a hundred times and I'm glad. Yeah.
Fifteen seconds they're all a dream and then I use a little knowledge. Be
these have two other
balloons and then that's why it's a little a spy was about two years ago.
From what you saw on
a recent story. We know that
my my my my in the My friends are this time
by All
right could you you know like to run
down. There you can just do what you
started to say. Than we do we
get out there your
morning and you know why some muffin
again and and they help a lot
about those that's such a rainbow one minute.
And then I stop for a guy sixty secs to come
now and I think come down like a round circle for this and come
now at the sixty seconds I don't eat all day having
class and then I can put. You lift the flag up you know
they know what they're doing going to meet you come out you stay here they'll
tell
you in the morning you have
classes tend to see a love
scene.